in the penultimate episode of Star Trek
Picard's first season lassie Renner
finally reaches its destination
Soji learns a truth of our origins and
Picard season unexpected familiar face
here are all the Easter eggs and
references you might have missed in
Athena kardia a yo part 1 but last year
Anna finally arrives at Sochi s
homeworld Saudi reveals that the planet
synthetic inhabitants call it cop alias
this is almost surely a reference to the
19th century ballet Coppelia in which a
young man falls in love with a life-size
doll in the ballet the dolls inventor
dr. koop alias plans to sacrifice the
young man in order to bring his creation
to life however the young man's fiancee
manages to save him by dressing up as
the doll and using COPE aliases other
creations are the distraction so that
the young couple can escape the first
part of the plot sounds eerily similar
to offer Karl and his crew encounter on
the planet scope alias where dr. Olssen
Inigo soon is willing to sacrifice the
lives of all organics in order to ensure
the continued existence of his sentient
synthetic creations surely after last
Sirena first arrives at coppola Nurik
ship also emerges from the transwarp
conduits and immediately begins to
attack after trading shots back and
forth norik ship suddenly seems to be
experiencing some sort of technical
malfunction with its cloaking device
glitching out and naros life signs
quickly fading but card orders Nurik
beamed aboard laughs - Renner but it
turns out it was all just a distraction
the ship they were seeing was actually a
projection of NAR X cloaking device
really his ship was behind last Sirena
and he exploited their attempt at mercy
to attack them again while the mechanics
are different Narvik strategy is
extremely reminiscent of the Picard
maneuver a battle tactic Picard invented
while commanding the stargazer that
created the illusion of a second ship
and blowing into maximum warp speed you
appeared for an instant to be in two
places at once and our attacker fired on
the wrong one
although nar accused his cloaking device
to create that illusion both tactics
involved confusing the opposing ships
sensors and tricking them into firing on
the illusion instead of the real ship
after lassie Rena crashed lands on the
surface of co-pay leus the ship seems
largely undamaged
that none of the ships automated systems
are up and running this presents a
problem for Agnes jarate who is tasked
with figuring out what's wrong with
Picard after the Admirals start speaking
nonsensically on the bridge although the
medical scanners on working IV no slug
sails when she finds an old med kit I
didn't know how I was gonna run a scan
on you and then I found this an
old-school medical tricorder of course
medical tricorder czar familiar to
anyone who was watched previous
iterations of Star Trek but the most
significant person from Picard's past to
use a medical tricorder was dr. Beverly
Crusher the chief medical officer on
board the enterprise
dr. crusher was also Picard's closest
friend and in one version of the future
his wife although they later got
divorced when the last C Rena crew
ventures out onto the surface of cope
Elias rafi attributes her nerves to the
possibility of encountering angry Raptor
lights or homicidal fungi neither of
these is outside the realm of
possibilities on Star Trek in the
original series the most notable
encounter with an angry reptile oyd
occurred in the episode arena in which
Captain Kirk is told he must fight to
the death with a captain of a gone ship
as homicidal fungi
well no Star Trek crew has yet had a
run-in with murderous mushrooms in the
original series episode the conscience
of the king the crew of the enterprise
encounters a former governor of a colony
responsible for massacring 4 thousand of
his colonists after an aggressive strain
of exotic fungi wiped out most of their
food stores the governor's justification
for his homicidal actions was that he
was trying to ensure that at least some
of his people would live even if it
meant sacrificing many of them this is
not too far off from the logic presented
by Sutra in Ettin Arcadia a go part 1 in
which she argues that wiping out all
organic life in the universe it's a
worthwhile trade-off if it ensure that
the synthetic race will live on after
arriving on cope alias the long-range
sensors on the crashed Borg cube confirm
that a fleets of Romulan warbirds is
indeed on its way to the planets and
will arrive and comfortably soon roughy
tells Rios that in total there are 218
warbirds approaching although Rafi jokes
that they really only have to worry
about the first 109 what it's always
hard to say for sure where the numbers
like these are supposed to be a
reference to anything at all 218 could
be an odd
fifth season next generation episode
cause and effect which was given
production code to 18 in the episode the
enterprise gets caught in a time loop
and only manages to escape once data
figures out a way to send a message to
himself through time giving him the
information he needs to break the loop
in Etten Arcadia a go part 1 Sutra
realizes that the admonition is a
message being sent from an ancient race
of synthetics to the synthetic
life-forms of the future keeping with
the idea of production codes the next
generation episode justice was given the
code 109 and sees Picard facing off
against a powerful and holy and fans
being who watches over a race of less
advanced people and just as Picard
opposes the death sentence given to an
innocent member of his crew arguing that
there is nothing just about such an
extreme unilateral punishment that
doesn't take individual circumstances
into accounts a similar argument to the
one we see him attempt to make at the
end of at in Arcadia a go part 1 when
Picard and the crew of lassie Rena
arriving cope alias station we get a
brief glimpse of two synthetics playing
a game that looks very similar to the 3d
chess that has been seen on several
other versions of Star Trek one episode
of the next generation in which 3d chess
played a prominent role was in a third
season episode in which Will Riker uses
his captors game to maneuver his way out
of his cell after he and Deanna Troi are
taken hostage the car would likely have
to employ similar levels of cunning and
strategic thinking in order to escape
the circumstances he finds himself in at
the end of at in Arcadia a go part 1
when the golden skins synthetic sutra is
introduced dr. Soong mentions that she
is extremely interested in Vulcan
culture saying that she is red su rock
and plays a kathira beautifully and has
even thoughts herself to perform a
Vulcan mind-meld su rock was a revered
Vulcan philosopher who helped shape
Vulcan culture with his teachings on
peace and logic meanwhile kuvira was a
former Vulcan lute it is a five stringed
instrument tuned on a diatonic scale it
can be very soothing several characters
have played the kaffarah in past
iterations of Star Trek including Spock
and Uhura on the original series and two
Vulcan Voyager one of the cuddliest
recurring characters on the next
generation was data's ginger house cat
spots who appeared in numerous
caring for spots and bonding that the
cat was a pivotal part of datas ongoing
quest to become more human and you must
park to him telling me is a pretty cat
and a good cat in at in Arcadia ego part
one Agnes's seen cuddling a remarkably
familiar ginger house cats whom she
confirms as even named spots ooh but
don't get too excited about spots family
tree continuing on through $23.99 this
version of Sparta is actually a
synthetic created by soon and seemingly
modeled after the original spots check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about Star
Trek are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]